عيوننا على جيبنا وهي تهتف
بأنهم يحتجون خارج فرع
وزارة المالية اللبنانية
،
تقف الحكومة
والسياسيون الذين يقودونها على مدى ثلاثة عقود مؤشرًا متهمًا بيع كومارا
سنجانا على تعميد المنشأة الجديدة.
قلت إن دوللي ماكجرو مابيل قلت إن
الفساد في لبنان يتراوح من الرشاوى البسيطة إلى
مخطط بونزي المعقد حيث يمتلك العديد من
السياسيين حصة في البنوك التي
قدمت قروضًا للدولة بأسعار
فائدة مرتفعة للغاية لإعادة بناء
البنية التحتية للبلاد بعد الحرب الأهلية لكن
البنية التحتية  لا يزال لبنان في حالة من الفوضى
، ليس لدى لبنان الكثير لإظهاره فيما يتعلق بديونه التي تزيد
عن 80 مليار دولار ، كما يقول
المراسل الاستقصائي رياض كابيزا
عن الأموال التي اقترضناها من
السياسيين لم يتحدثوا ولم
يصلوا الكهرباء ولم يصلحوا المياه
هم  لم يتم إصلاح أي شيء
بشكل جيد ، فلماذا يتعين علينا
إعادة الأموال بسعر
فائدة مرتفع للغاية
لقد دفع السياسيون
بالكلام للتنظيف
قالوا إن هذه مهمة مستحيلة لما
يزيد قليلاً عن عام ، طريق نيكولا بالقرب
من وزارة الدولة التي انتهت صلاحيتها الآن لمكافحة
الفساد ، وقد أعاقت السياسات المعقدة في البلاد
جهوده
السلطة الدينية بالإضافة إلى الحزب السياسي بالإضافة إلى
الحرب العالمية الرب  حسنًا ، خط أحمر
لا يمكنك ذلك لأنك
رأيت الأب الروحي ولأنك تعرف كيف
يحدث ذلك ليس بعيدًا جدًا.
أثمرت ثمارها على الورق على الأقل ،
تقول الرئيسة اللبنانية ميشيل الخاصة
إنه تم فتح سبعة عشر ملفًا متعلقًا بالفساد
للتحقيق ، كما يجري التحقيق في
الشؤون المالية لرئيسي وزراء سابقين
، لكن
رد فعل العديد من اللبنانيين هو لماذا لم يتم
ذلك
قبل الاحتجاجات  استمر مع
ازدياد ثراء الأغنياء وفقر الجميع ،
اتسعت الفجوة بين الحكام والمحكومين أكثر من
أي وقت مضى ، كما يقول بولي
العالم سامي
عطالا ليس لديهم إيمان أو ثقة
والحكومة والأحزاب السياسية
التي أدارت الحكومة على
مدى الثلاثين عامًا الماضية لتخليص لبنان من
الفساد
، يجب أن يذهب الكثير من المتظاهرين وهم بحاجة إلى سيينا
[تصفيق]